I am a huge fan right now of
uh is it zhaoa and wo long get up zza
and
woong zza is a 36y old yeah this one go
to the third one down there this is a
good one uh she is from a province in
China and she's big on Chinese Tick Tock
and her friend wulong is kind of a
hunchback and zzza has her own issues
but um and this
transgender presenter in China China
seems kind of fun like I know that we're
all supposed to be afraid of
China but if this is what's going on in
China Count Me In they've got this
transgender presenter who's very
polished and put together uh who looks
very good she's like going the full you
know she's really she's going the full
you
know whatever it is you know doing it uh
I don't want to say right doing it well
it's
nice you know I'm going to get in
trouble for saying this and I and people
are going to get angry with me and I
don't know I'm just
saying sometimes it's nice to see a
transgender person really
try do you understand what I
mean because I like effort in every part
of life do you understand it's not I'm
only I'm not simply requiring it of
someone who's transitioning or changing
genders I want it all over the
place but I do like it when I see
someone who is
transgender really commit to it and
really try to the best of their own
Financial ability Mark Norman used to
have a great joke about that where he
was like people say this one's Brave
she's just rich or whatever you know but
I like to see somebody try which this
host in China is doing and this is kind
of like I guess a Chinese American Idol
in a
way I don't know I don't know if that's
what it it is but let's give everyone a
taste of this if you don't know who
these people
are this will
be cultural prediction
here this will be more common we are
going to find people that are
formed because this is kind of the Final
Phase of society where it's really the
barbarism is coming I every week I try
not to do this by the way like every
week I go I drive here and I go you know
I know why I'm not as big as like other
people it's just because it's like how
much can you take of this right like
even me like even me sometimes right I'm
like how much can I take like I want to
do other things like I had a nice
friends giving I talk about that I could
talk about entertaining I like I like
throwing uh you know parties and seeing
people get together who cares right but
I get it like like I was like today on
the way here I was like I'm not going to
do the whole it's fall the Empire is
falling in a CL I I'm not g to do it but
I really I sometimes I don't want to do
it but it's just it's now what is there
it's so if it's you know there's it's
it's hard to infer anything else from
the news is my point it's difficult I
try to to infer we're going to go later
Fox News literally has an article that's
like here's how you can have a
Thanksgiving without killing people that
you
know because they're so used to the
people that watch Fox News as being like
I guess like monsters that they
literally every line is like well you
know you don't you know don't keep a
loaded gun at the table like it's it's
such a
crazy article but what I mean here about
Xiao Xiao and woong and I think why
they're an important you know I know
that I mean even as I say this it seems
insane but what's important about xiaa
and wulong is
that we're I believe what's coming is a
real fascination with deformed people
kind of freaks it's going back to the
1920s as it was in the beginning as it
shall be in the end I believe we are
going back to the kind of tent era
depression tent era Carnival Sideshow
circus this is what I believe this is
kind of the final form of a lot of the
trends that we've seen on the
internet these people are probably being
abused they're being used but they're
getting their Fame and you know people
are going to say this is a good thing
you know people people debate this they
go these are these SE people are being
abused and then other people go no
they're not they love it and no one
knows what's going on because no one
lives in this crazy province of China
but I think her family's probably like
we're making a little bit of money here
people like that she's an odity she's an
odity and this was the thinking behind
the freak Show right this person is an
odity but why not
pay money to see them
because so this is what a lot of tick
tock has become we are putting humans on
display and human
Oddities and we
are marveling at them we're
gawking and the latest manifestation of
this is Xiao Xiao and wulong who by the
way I feel an affection for both of them
and I enjoy what they're doing xia xia
is kicks and hits because she's often
angry at others which I often feel very
enraged and I
feel kind of envious of her of her
ability to kind of just kind of wo long
her friend who only I've read about them
for several hours and woa I had a party
it's funny you know I had this
friendsgiving
and I I you talk what I like about it is
you don't talk to anyone for that long
you do your little thing with everybody
you go over to Caitlyn Jenner how are
you she's talking about patriotism love
it go over to Barry Weiss What's your
deal the Jews good moving on we go over
to tan Mojo like her what's going on
with the
you're just quick quick in and out
Bobby Lee Lovely to meet your girl girl
this one that one that one you know
Santino a bunch of people came but for a
lot of the party I was reading about xia
xia and wulong because I was I'm
transfixed and they said this all
started because Xiao Xiao they they they
were doing some type of benefit for xiaa
they brought her out she sang a song or
people liked it supposedly Wu only spoke
one word before she
started doing social
media these are the Chinese demilios you
know how we have Charlie demilio and
Dixie
demilio this is what they have and I
take these two over the demilios any day
of the week without further Ado if you
don't know him you will they're going to
be household
names uh is this show part of the
problem or part of the solution I don't
know I don't know if there's a real
difference xia and
[Music]
now if that's what Wonka was I'd watch
it Shia wulong find them support them on
other
channels wulong doesn't sing often she's
chill but she does sing sometimes you
know this is what's happening this is
where where life is going